well the list keeps growing tonight of
countries expelling Russian diplomats
over the poisoning of a former Kremlin
spy in England Australia Belgium Ireland
and Moldova made the moves today so did
the NATO alliance we're getting more
reaction tonight here at home as well
correspondent kevin cork is at the White
House with the latest we're certainly
applying pressure hours after announcing
the expulsion of dozens of Russian
diplomats following the dangerous nerve
agent attack on a Russian porn agent on
British soil President Trump spoke by
telephone with several international
leaders notably Canada's Trudeau Francis
McCrone and Germany's Merkel in an
expression of solidarity for their
responses which saw more than a hundred
Russians expelled from countries across
the globe we're certainly encouraging
and working with our allies and partners
also to do so and I think you've seen an
unprecedented number of countries step
up and join the United States in that
effort
defense secretary Jim mattis today told
reporters that the poisoning amounted to
quote an attempted murder by the Russian
government saying Russia has chosen to
be a strategic competitor even to the
point of reckless activity NATO leaders
called yesterday's explosions the
clearest sign yet that the Russians plan
to sow discord in the West simply won't
work sense a very clear message to
Russia that it has costs and I actually
think that Russia has underestimated the
unity of NATO allies the Kremlin warned
it would act in reciprocal fashion in
response to what its foreign minister
called
a Washington coordinated effort meant to
bully his country of study Missouri when
one or two diplomats are asked to leave
this with that country whispering
apologies to our ears we know for sure
that this is a result of colossal
pressure and colossal blackmail which
are used by Washington as the main
instrument in the international scene
while his surrogates have spoken in
instead the President himself has
remained silent for hours on the
decision to expel the Russians and to
close a consular facility near Seattle
passing on his penchant for tweeting on
Russia it's threatened response even the
stormy Daniel saga this while the White
House counsel's office is under
increasing pressure to produce documents
related to
review of senior advisor Jared Kushner's
compliance with ethics laws to Democrats
on the House Oversight Committee are
looking into Kushner's meetings with
executives from two companies that later
loaned millions to his family's business
right all this is happening as these
stormy Daniel saga continues the very
latest twist her camp is now suing the
president's private attorney Michael
Cohen
claiming he has defamed her right Kevin
cork live at the White House Kevin thank
you